three two one check check okay it's
happening
[Music]
you're checking you're checking and I'm
I'm peeking on Peak hey all right
welcome back everyone we are on episode
109 finally cover we've been covering
the situationist international for about
a month but this is the one book that
everyone remembers as being produced by
the situationist international and Gita
board probably the figurehead at least
of the late period the society
definitely the spectacle in case we're
not clear about that I remember this
book you you two know uh my friend
Jordan I don't know what the right word
I wouldn't describe it as conservative
but certainly more like of a traditional
academic person who likes to read like
the classics but from I guess more of a
conservative side and I remember him and
I were doing like a bit of a reading
group at one point and I think he didn't
really like know what this book was
about and suggested it and we started
reading it and he just was like I'm not
really interested in continuing this
because it turned out to be just way
more of a Marxist critique than he
thought it was I think he thought it was
going to be more or speak to like
societal nihilism which to some extent
it does but from like a much more left
kind of material and like kind of
marxist analysis perspective whereas I
think like he's more interested in the
question of nihilism as maybe presented
by like a Nietzsche or someone like that
right as opposed to kind of the more
Marxist side so yeah this is very much a
precursor to beaudryard in that sense
because beaudryard will do the
metaphysics stuff about reality having
disappeared whereas this is much more I
guess you could say Orthodox Marxist in
the sense is like we we're forgetting
reality it's still there point at it
look at it we can't forget about that
yeah yeah yeah it's true yeah I mean the
the question of the real world will be
interesting but yeah I see a lot of
pre-figurations also some continuations
of like especially like Walter Benjamin
and some of the kind of revisionist
marxist stuff coming out in the early
20th century but then yeah a lot of
second half of the 20th century
and it's worth mentioning I mean if you
just go to your go to your University
library and search you'll find all kinds
of new articles still coming up citing
whether they're just trying to update
the whole thing like there's a book
called spectacle 2.0 for the digital age
and social media Lots on social media
the spectacle on social media is an
extension of the spectacle yeah okay
speaking of I don't really like to do
news updates just because it kind of
dates our episodes but I found a little
bit of news that I had to share with you
guys and I'm I'm guessing that you
haven't seen it yet but it relates to
the spectacle and relates to
the spectacle 2.0 or just hell world
hyperreal
so two days ago
I'm gonna try to paint a word picture
here two days ago on okay the popular
website twitter.com I saw a video heard
of it
the video or Twitter
I've heard I've heard of Twitter you've
heard of twitter.com oh thank you I saw
a video I have heard it on this video
was a guy a streamer
don't remember his name but he was
apologizing for watching porn
because in a live stream he had
apparently like clicked to a tab and
then his followers like zoomed in on the
tab and found out what he was looking at
so I already I found this on Twitter
it's about a live stream we're already
we're already in a degree of the hyper
real in this video out of focus in the
background is this guy's girlfriend
who's crying into a Kleenex while he
talks about porn wow what yeah so this
is wait I don't care no wait wait I got
I gotta finish the rest of the story
because this is the kind of thing yeah
there's more it feels like this happens
basically every week these days that
you're like if I went if I sent a letter
to myself back in time if I sent myself
a letter
five years ago even let alone 10 years
ago but just five years ago explaining
what happened here to myself I would
think you know what it's over we're done
I'm not going to say anymore now but no
no no we're done okay so what happened
the reason this guy brought his
girlfriend in soft focus she's out of
focus crying in the background while he
talks and apologizes the thing that he
was apologizing for
was
watching AI generated porn
of people that he knows personally deep
fake who are also famous because he's a
famous streamer and they're famous
streamers who are women and he was
watching
or got caught I guess got caught
watching AI generated porn of his own
friends oh my God and then decided that
his girlfriend had to come and watch the
video with him while she cried and he oh
he was crying too so this is yeah it was
very emotional
I don't know if I understand those
emotions though that's a very confusing
scene you've painted for us there yeah
and then and then all these kind of
streamer because I follow a lot of this
the Twitter streamers
it started to like all the kind of
debate Bros started talking about
whether or not
um like the ethics of watching deep fake
porn
you know like is it is there something
morally wrong with oh yeah we could talk
about this is this is straight up
beaudryard breaking news like what is
what is an image if you put because an
AI porn it's like someone's I think it's
a face on a different face right you can
do this with like political figures also
yeah yeah so it's pudding it's kind of
like if you've seen those videos of like
people yeah but this is putting your
friends faces onto porn star bodies and
watching it oh and the other thing is
that he paid for it which is oh my God I
think breaking a rule of the internet is
paying for points oh but he also paid
to watch AI generated images of his
friends having sex wow that's weird tell
yourself that tell yourself this five
years ago tell yourself this 10 years
ago this is the world now this is hyper
real hell world and I don't even want to
this doesn't really actually relate to
the Society of the spectacle which is
the topic of the day but in terms of
whether there is a real world underneath
all the worlds
I mean this this raises some questions
wow I mean I should make a
they should reboot that I love you man
make and make a second movie Follow that
up about this
I think this gets into like questions of
what is the image first of all like
philosophically not personally because
personally it's probably really
violating to see your face put on a body
that's getting railed
yeah yeah but then what is the image do
you have ownership over your image I saw
people put out a you know the beat the
artist people the I don't know really
famous nft dude uh vaguely because he
also uh this week made an image of
Tucker Carlson
doggy styling the green m m girl
oh my God
because he's very he's very Tucker
Carlson is very horny over what shoes
the m m girl wears because it has to do
with the the woke left and all this
stuff so I don't know if you're gonna
pass a law that says people own their
images then people can't make the image
of Tucker Carlson [__] a green m m
but you'd also get rid of the the
violation felt at Deep fakes and not
having control over your own image being
sexualized but are we just all objects
this is the revenge of the object as
bodrad would say I mean you'd have to
I mean you'd really have to if you'd
really have to fiddle with that law
because it also would depend on how
saturated our media environment is with
certain people's images right
like certain people are just much more
visible
but those sort of political ones I've
seen
well I think that's the reason that the
AI can create some people and not others
because it presumably you'd need like a
large data set of images to be able to
deep fake someone with their face at
different angles I would guess and if
you're doing their whole body if you're
just smashing a face onto some other
body then maybe not so difficult but
I've seen those political
attack kind of deep fakes in there yeah
yeah it's it's you know when you have
vulnerable kinds of people or in in
political office then it can get
problematic whereas I mean with Tucker
Carlson I don't feel bad because he
constantly just he just uses his
platform to attack people and so he's
just getting a bit of his own medicine
but for other people it's not so good so
you can really just blanket that be like
everyone now owns their own image it's
like oh my God
the question would be how to how to
determine
sexualization because Tucker Carlson
[__] an Eminem is definitely
sexualization but then how do you
legislate it to make one illegal and not
the other how do you differentiate from
parity like can you if you own your
image can people make political cartoons
of you
so I yeah I'm glad I'm not I'm glad I'm
not in charge of it yeah glad I'm not on
that ethics review board
my God
my God anyway to the topic of the day
we've been covering
the situationist international for about
a month as I said this is their their
Apex output
and as Eric said still being used still
being referenced and we read just the
first three chapters of it for today
but the Society of spectacle it might be
the book at least in my circles
whose title is dropped more than that of
any other book because you someone sees
a commercial they see an advertisement
something goes off on Instagram
Instagram and then it's oh yeah of
course we live in a society of spectacle
and is that
I wonder if that is that right is there
any other book title that is referenced
more as just its own concept like the
work of art and the age of mechanical
reproduction does come to mind
hyper real but that's not the type of
title of a book a simulacra simulacum
maybe post-modernism and the the
cultural logic of late capitalism that
comes up yeah it kind of became like a
meme a meme a meme sept
yeah I I think you're right
anyway we are here today to do something
like a close reading
um just to see what what does it mean
and what doesn't it mean because it
doesn't mean
every advertisement you see and it
doesn't mean every political spectacle
you see he's kind of intentional about
what it means so and yeah it doesn't
mean the mass media either that's kind
of what we want to think of
the mass media is kind of just a
reductive idea when you're talking about
the spectacle
but it does have to do with images so
we'll talk a lot about that and images I
mean I guess implicitly we've been
discussing them all along because the
art aspect of the situationist is all
about taking
what what classical pieces of art sort
of like like done in the classical
realist style and I don't know what is
he drawing ducks on them or something
like that almost like a kind of a kind
of like a theoretical or a high art
vandalism
so it's about D what was that what was
our word
um
yeah they're detouring the these images
already so this this is almost like a
totalization of the theory behind that
of of taking images and and and
graffiting them and and putting them up
and and but but discussing it because
the spectacle is more than just images
it's more than just things we see images
on like mediums media it's it's uh it
involves a lot
so when people do use this like meme you
know spectacle
it's often not completely grasping I
mean I'm I'm guilty of this myself but
without completely grasping what the
board means by spectacle and
and how it relates to to uh social
theory critical theory yeah for sure
I I use it that way too just offhandedly
but in the way that he brings it up and
the way that he develops it there's no
way to separate it from Marx's political
economy I mean I think that's the the
main point is you you can't you can't
use this independently of that even the
first line of the book is a reference to
Capital
yeah it's almost like a paraphrase or
almost like a detour in MA of of uh of a
paragraph of capital so actually so yeah
can you read the first
I'll read the first uh lines of capital
and can you read the first uh line of
the book
so like aphorism what do you mean yeah
aphorism one so the beginning of capital
opens with the wealth of those Societies
in which the capitalist mode of
production prevails presents itself as
an immense accumulation of Commodities
its unit being a single commodity our
investigation must therefore begin with
the analysis of a commodity
yeah and then that is uh transposed here
in thesis one I'm going to call them
Theses I don't know they feels right to
me the whole life quote the whole life
of these those Societies in which the
modern conditions of production Prevail
presents itself as an immense
accumulation of spectacles
all that once was directly lived has
become mere representation at at least
that's what my translation says my
translation is pretty similar but it
says in societies where Modern
conditions of production Prevail life is
presented as an immense accumulation of
spectacles everything that was directly
lived has receded into a representation
Ah that's interesting
so it's not a direct reproduction of
Marx but where Mark says commodities
we are now saying spectacles plural
instead so he does seem to be following
like Marx's logic and it and it is
dialectical here he is he is applying a
kind of dialectical reasoning right like
one thing creates its opposite and then
once that thing develops to a certain
point it's opposite then becomes or it's
contrary then becomes significant and
then as that develops you know you know
that kind of dialectical reasoning
process that like Hegel and Marx have
have developed and and it's still to me
a very counter-intuitive way of thinking
about things but it produces texts like
this and then you gotta try and figure
out what's going on
and understand that they are thinking in
this way
and the other thing that's noteworthy is
that Mark says this is capitalist
production
and Deborah says this is modern
conditions of production
so I think implied in there he could
have very easily used the word
capitalist mode of production and he
does elsewhere in the text but he
decides to call this the modern mode of
production
as if there's something about capitalism
that doesn't apply here and I think
we'll we'll see that as we go through
the text
the capitalism is being subsumed by
something other than it
or sort of a growth that emerges from
within it
a tumor
his use of plurals there is interesting
too because in like you can say again
this about Marxist things the wealth of
societies in which this is the qualifier
in which the capitalist mode of
production prevails suggesting that
there are Societies in which the
capitalist mode of production does not
Prevail are that there are other modes
of production and so I don't know what
immense accumulation of spectacles is
perhaps following that logic because the
book is titled Society of the Society of
the spectacle
and so to use spectacles in the plural
here is very confusing and perhaps it's
also kind of trying to reproduce that
that aspect of Marx's statement is that
there are
other other modes of production other
Society other spectacles but
we're we're not going to get too far in
before we say it has to like the
commodity form has to be dominant and
presumed in that domination is kind of a
global market immediately it seems like
there are no other modes of production
we've talked about this a lot over the
last month that the situationist
international they have kind of a goal
and their goal is something about Unity
and not Unity as in hegemony but Unity
as opposed to the way modern society is
laid out and the modern city is laid out
which is what we talked about last week
like this efficiency and specialization
of all zones of life and and the city
too you know dividing
um rich and poor dividing work and
Leisure
all of this leads to a fragmentation of
Human Experience into
being a producer all day and then a
consumer in in your leisure time and
these are completely separate Realms
work Leisure and here the world is split
into what he keeps calling the real or
the or real life and then the spectacle
and the spectacle is this it's a split
from the real that's almost taking it
over so Direct
or real life
and then this pseudo world of images on
top so this I mean boudread comes to
mind a lot here because border art is
the one who says the real has
disappeared and we're not yet there
remember this is uh
like 1967.
so
he's he's very concerned the book about
taking care of this reel or returning to
it or asserting it or I don't know I
don't know what you call his goals here
because his goals are kind of opaque
but there's a fragmentation in the world
and the fragmentation is somehow related
to all these images
but we want to restore a sense of unity
to it I'll just direct quote just to hit
the point home
fragmented views of reality regroup
themselves into a new Unity as a
separate pseudo world that can only be
looked at so the spectacle unifies but
it's it unifies what we already have
which is the fragmented the separate the
different forms of life the ones that
don't meet up and I think he's trying to
like get hit home that we have a
psychological condition
where our reality is just broken
and this is part of it so that implies I
guess I mean I don't want to get into
critiques right now but
I think
it's just hard not to
notice the way that's implying that
there is such a thing as like you know
uh lived directly world or a you know
real world or a you know unified world
and maybe that's just the like
consistent with
more well it's consistent with Marxism I
guess it more than it is other kind of
Continental thinkers who we explore on
this podcast
um right who tend to emphasize more of
like disunity and like impossibility of
like a final order and stuff like that
so
obviously Marxist inspired stuff is
still maybe in the business of trying to
recover or create some harmonious
Unified
like real world I think oh yeah that's
ah I'm trying to figure it out but I
don't think it's Marxism that he gets
this from specifically because he talks
about this as the technology of mass
media
and for us it's hard to like
you know beam our mind back into the
time except for the fact that
kind of like I opened up with we're
dealing with every week it seems like
something
that we would have never understood 10
years ago even us being alive from it
but I think this applies to them as well
because on one hand this sounds like a
kind of a shitty we live in a society
critique
but in 1967 this was the the decade that
most
people got their first TV inside their
house
at least in France and they had like two
channels and they weren't 24 hours so
their experience I mean his experience
of this fragmentation
that he he does say specifically has to
do with the media technology is I think
maybe something that we can't understand
but if we if we frame it in that context
of
now
I think over the course of the 60s it
went from like 13 of of French homes
having TV to like 80 just over the
decade so it it became
that it's it's
hard to imagine you know the immense
development that's occurred over even
just the 20th century never mind since
like the Industrial Revolution
electrification
etc etc
but yeah I don't know if
just picking up what Victor was just
saying too
um yeah the real world right like so
does this fall under like we recently
been talking about like rorty and his
his kind of anti-representationalism
where you have representations and you
have the real world and representations
refer to the Real Worlds and this is a
view he calls representationalism and he
just wants nothing to do with it he
doesn't want realism and he doesn't want
idealism or what he calls it just calls
anti-realism he thinks those are both
representationalist theories because
they
adhere to some kind of external referent
that guarantees the truth of a
representation
but I'm sure he would be immediately
suspicious and we're all suspicious good
critical constructivists of any claims
about the Real Worlds either the loss of
or getting back to it but again I think
there's more going on here than just
something like that you know how the
Matrix
film thinks it's about beaudryard and
then bodegaard was like this is the kind
of film that the Matrix would have made
yeah they should have just used this
book instead
because this book says oh behind
everything we can get we can get to the
production relationships and for him the
real doesn't mean like the experiential
real necessarily it's really about
what we call material conditions as a
representation who owns what who does
what and what is your like social
relationship before being mediated by
the TV that just showed up in your house
that wasn't there
five years ago right
what's that that lie I know I know this
stake isn't real but I don't care yeah
exactly and so many of the popular
critiques of social media are doing the
same thing
if you read New York Times then social
media is the cause of polarization it's
the cause of kids not going to the park
it's the cause of
radicalization as if this didn't appear
before now the board is doing something
a little bit different and a little bit
better I think which is to say this is
maximalizing an aspect that already
existed in the split the capitalist
split of being a producer 50 of the time
and then a consumer the other half of
the time and then being an owner in the
capitalist mode of production or being a
slave a worker in the capitalist mode of
production so this thing the spectacle
is intensifying a split that already
exists and it's not like TV is
responsible for it but TV just allows it
to become an absorber or a an energy
form where all we ever do and I see this
I mean I see this clearly
all we ever do is talk about what the
other person is talking about so become
spectacle on spectacle
and then the conditions of who owns what
or the conditions of who's making what
never really come into question
and I think that's the thing that he's
pointing to is our consciousnesses and
he says the word false consciousness a
couple times our consciousnesses have
been absorbed into this one thing
where it's the only the only place that
exchange happens which doesn't deny that
there's like a real economy in his terms
but all of our energy is being put in
the same place I don't think that's
wrong either
that is some Matrix falling back on the
mass media it's just like
I don't know if this is even a good
analogy but it's like you know like it's
a one-way relationship right you sit in
front of the television and it speaks to
you you don't speak back right it's a
one-way relationship
and it has this this sort of it has this
sort of
end effect of of of isolating and
atomizing us
because again sort of following that
Marxist logic of of the commodity again
where
it's it congeals it's some it's like
almost magical it congeals he kind of
says the spectacle is not a collection
of images rather it's a social
relationship between people mediated by
images
that's one of his statements of what the
spectacle is it's a social relationship
between people mediated by images
and that's what makes me think you know
the real he's talking about is something
like what you find in in Marx's like
humanist manuscripts for instance like
it's a it's a social relation
so that I don't I don't think the real
is like the real you know
biophysical world out there and that
like when you watch a commercial for a
car it's not like telling you about the
physical and specs of the car right it's
just kind of presenting a lifestyle to
you this is a lifestyle Choice it's an
image decision it's it's a quality
you're going to attach to yourself it's
not like oh I better get the I better
get the Dodge because it's like a couple
miles per gallon better I don't know
that means people do think that way when
they're purchasing whatever but I mean
that's not how it's presented to you
that's not so it's not like a real
pre-existing world like the
representationalists problem
it's a real of social relations that are
now mediated
just in the same way and sort of Marx
and his analysis now here we have it
mediated by the spectacle it's a relate
it's a social relationship between
people
that is mediated by images doesn't the
spectacle though reflect something about
human beings
like I think
like isn't it reflecting something true
like so I I guess I know I'm falling
into critique here again but like why is
it always could like framed as being
this external thing that kind of like
pacifies us
like isn't it a creation a co-creation
of like human beings and it's
stimulating things and it and it's able
to make us I guess passive to certain
conditions
precisely because to some extent it's an
accurate reflection of human beings
right it's not actually as alien and
unreal it's actually just
like a reflection somehow that then
obviously mystifies and distorts in its
own ways but I guess I I would want to
resist this kind of
what seems like a bit of a Stark
divide or a stark kind of saying okay
like it's this thing that is mediating
in this like particularly inauthentic
way
um but like I think
he like if there's a reason it's working
because it's reflecting something true
I don't think I would not say reflecting
I would say producing okay
I think the spectacle is produced and
yeah everyone I finally produced every
one of us even at the very at the moment
right now
we are contributing to its production
but still
it's not a reflection as much as a
production
it's a it's a self-representation right
like you know you know when I was when I
was reading this I also got some you
know very distant very distant Echoes of
like second order cybernetics too saying
it's a self it's a self I mean in that
language it's it's self-referential it's
not referencing anything outside of
itself it's and he here he says it's
it's um
it's a it's a self-representation of to
the world
and it's superior to the worlds
but the problem again with using that
language of true and false like is it
something is there something true in it
I mean that's this first section we're
looking at is called the separation
perfected so there's something called a
separation and and some Perfection that
this development of the spectacle this
production of the spectacle brings it to
and the things that are separated are
the reality and the image
but then you go okay so the image is
false in reality is true great easy he
says no no not so fast because the true
false or the the real and illusion
dichotomy falls into then both sides
reality can be true or false and the
image can also be illusion illusory or
true
it doesn't work it falls onto both sides
of that separation and in the end the
the spectacle is the is the unity of
that separation right it's the unity of
that Separation by the way he does not
let the binary between true and false
last very long because he says in the
true lacanian form almost but he says
the split itself is split
so
I hate reading direct quotes but I'm
gonna do it the spectacle that falsifies
reality is nevertheless a real product
of that reality conversely real life is
materially invaded by the contemplation
of the spectacle and ends up absorbing
it and aligning itself with it so the
split because he says this is the the
spectacles of perfection
of the split but the split already
existed in Marx in the commodity and
commodity fetishism because the
commodity really in real life which is
not just you know offline life but in
real life is a relationship of Labor of
who made it and
as our real activity now begins to
imitate this the simulation you can
think especially of advertising best
example because then in that context you
have artists that start making art
that's indistinguishable from
advertisements like this [__] Andy
Warhol who just paints suit cans and
today it's the same thing with with like
influencer marketing where being
yourself means
you need Fake Plastic cheekbones on your
face to sell clutches because Kim
Kardashian has Fake Plastic cheekbones
to sell clutches yet at the same time
that simulation is still a product of
real what he calls real relations which
are Labor Relations or technological
infrastructure for example like Disney
and and CNN and Google they all have
owners and employees
and janitors
and those relations don't appear in the
products because the products conceal
the very relations that brought that
thing into the world so even us yeah
we're not outside of it but we're making
this social media [__]
we don't even know how we're we don't
even know the relations that brought
this stuff into being we don't know the
janitors and just talking back and forth
if we're gonna sit here and be like
look at the dumb thing Tucker Carlson
said and the dumb thing that Ben Shapiro
said we're taking only the content and
the form disappears in the content
and you you as listener you're complicit
also you can't just talk about Labor
Relations because then they're gone
already as soon as you start talking
about them and that's what the spectacle
does it's
appearance
mass media is concealed social relations
in the same way that Marx's commodity
was except
it also takes over your leisure time
you have no outside there's no outside
to capitalism
when both labor and Leisure which is
supposed to be spent doing your own [__]
now Leisure is commodified
commercialized productized also and we
are that product us right now
[__] yeah
I mean in a way right you're you're your
leisure time what you want to do how you
want to spend your your Vacations or
your downtime in a society of the
spectacle is not really your decision
you have various options out there you
can mimic you can reproduce you have
various options out there that are given
to you you're not doing it
I mean he the example he kind of uses is
is that your your gestures are not your
own anymore they're somebody else's
and hey he almost uses that as like a an
example
but I I think of it when I when I'm on
my way to work or something like that
and and and and some somebody's with
their kids and their kids or whatever
doing their thing you can tell that
their behavior all they really are is
just a bag of imitations of things
they've been watching on YouTube there's
no real person under all of that the
kids are just imitating and reenacting
and they're expressing themselves via
whatever the last [__] Disney movie
they've watched was they're not coming
up with things for themselves and and
for good reason why would you why would
you do all that work of of and chaining
a series of gestures of your own
creation when there's all these options
out there for you why would you do that
economize you fool right like it doesn't
why would you want to be this romantic
individual genius child no don't do it
but I mean that's that's the nature of
it right like it's not your own anymore
back in the Mythic days
people would go to the temple and they
would dance for the god in like
prescribed steps and all that and now we
dance for tick tocks
following the previous person who did
The Tick Tock dance
yeah take another dance for tick tock
than some God that doesn't exist Tick
Tock is the dark God and we must dance
for it and so and sacrifice our children
to it yeah like imagine something's
horrible is happening to you and you
think there's some deity that's angry at
you so you have to go and find a Bard
who can sing the theogony to you and
then figure out from that how to
sacrifice to that God properly in order
to alleviate whatever problems you're
having that would be a pain in the
[__] ass if I'm having a problem I
just gonna go watch TV until I find the
right commercial that tells me what I
need to do what drug I need or what what
product I need to buy to make everything
better so much [__] easier right why
have gods that don't exist when we just
have products right you know I wish I
wish like I actually love the experience
this is like an unpopular take
when I get advertised something that I
want I'm like sweet like thank you for
bringing this to my attention the
problem I have with advertisements that
normally it's trying to sell me [__] I
don't want
it's like do your job better advertising
Executives and actually show me
something that I want well there's an
algorithm for that I'm pretty sure based
on your previous and I hope it gets
better
yeah
I mean a lot of people will say that
it's but it it doesn't just it it
doesn't produce I mean sorry it doesn't
just give you what you want or reflect
what you want it also has to produce
want that's true yeah that's true yeah
producing desire I mean none of this I
mean again like though it's hard to talk
about this without sounding like you're
if you're making value claims about it I
mean no this is just what the spectacle
is doing I mean whatever the digital
spectacle can track your previous
activity and Target ads at you better
great whatever whatever it's just that's
just what's happening the value judgment
stuff is is for some other point not
some other stage of the process this is
the understanding and the description
process
and so if that's what's going on then
that's what's going on and we got to
figure it out and is this description
like is it because I noticed the
invocation of kind of
lookinian like language about the fact
that her desire is not really our own
desire right that in a way we're kind of
just reproducing kind of like
in Lacon it's like you know the other's
desire
how is that different
is it so is there just so is this just
an account of lacanian Desire except it
when it comes to commodity and like
images and media
it's just like
that's the content of it but the
structure of Desire itself is not
necessarily changed
it's just that the way that the media is
interacting in that Dynamic and images
create is
unique in a way
well I think it's yeah like I think it
touches on a lot of the same territory
but I mean it's a different way of
looking at it it's like you know
delusion gotari is a different way of
conceiving desire than the lacanian
option you know reading anti-edipus
gives you a different you know reading
reading one set of economic theories and
reading another one where reading
marginalist Theory or whatever like you
know yeah they're about the same thing
but they're different theories of the
same thing
so so they get some things right and
something's wrong yeah it's interesting
I actually remember when I was one of
the first papers graduate papers I wrote
in my PhD I was in like a Nietzsche
class
uh and at the time I think that might
have been around the time when I first
started reading the Society of the
spectacle and I remember that that whole
paper was really just about the way in
which
Nietzsche actually gave like a kind of
lookinian reading of Nietzsche
as trying to recover something or trying
to get to Something Real like you know
and that for him the role it's been a
while but was you know this category of
like real life or true you know the um
I'm forgetting the word but but it's
kind of like you know our our instincts
for life you know uh
and then and then I feel like I remember
comparing to Rousseau and comparing to
Freud and and I remember thinking that
the board I mean all this language too
even the title of the first chapter of
the book right it's like separation
perfected and I think
you know separation from what I mean I
guess we were talking about that a
little bit uh already in terms of the
unity but
you know what is
what what is separate separation from
like something like what is that
separation I think is kind of the
question
I'm wondering well we've done we've
dealt with this for a month it's a unity
of life and a unity of life experience
well we can get there with these first
which never existed never existed okay
for him
it did
at least in terms of like survival so
you don't need a political economy of
exchange value if survival is the goal
of life
yeah you kind of have to but sure but
here's the difference though is the
difference in in modern society there is
obviously like very little that is tied
to survival for most people but for
example what we talked about last week
with the city layouts there's certain
cities where you also need a car to be
able to live like you need it yeah it's
not it's not it's not optional
so need independent of political economy
is the split that he's already talking
about but the original split already was
diagnosed by Marx and he's not really
moving that far beyond even even that
bit except to say that
our needs are wholly superficial to
either living a good life
and again this is questionable but what
he means by living a good life but it
means not having all these splits really
yeah unalienated but it yeah you kind of
have to accept that this is
since it's since it's fastened to
Marxism it's a historical argument
there's a point where the capitalist
mode of production was not dominant and
then before then social relations looked
different they're mediated and expressed
on a different economic basis so you
have to understand that it's a
historical argument just just as
beaujriard even has his whole history
what does he have that three or four
stage argument of leading up to the
simulacrum he kind of has that layered
kind of pseudo-historical development
perspective as well that's that's here
too the society appears at a certain
stage of development of the modern mode
of production he calls it
and you know whatever
I don't know again like is Mark saying
that earlier modes of production people
live more authentically under them no
he's not saying that it's just a
different configuration there's a
different superstructure a different
kind of ideology that goes along with
that but in each case the ruling class
is the one that's expressing those ideas
and the ruling class is the one who now
administers this Society of the
spectacle the spectacle is administered
by the bourgeois
and it's there in a sense it's but
they're they're out of the picture it's
it seems to us it's just there for
itself it's
independent it's objective and we're
involved in it but only as Spectators
because there's a one-way relationship
we can't he says we can't talk back to
it in a certain way it's just always
like okay well what about what about Web
Web 2.0 now you can sort of talk back to
the internet but
I don't know I don't think that changes
a whole lot of the fundamentals of this
argument even today
is that it's a spectacle
I think if you need a way to read this
more charitably as of like oh do we go
back to something or anything like that
I think the thing that he is trying to
wake people up to and the thing that he
is very much
successful at waking up or Waking people
up to because of the
like how often this book is referenced
and quoted is that we're not we're not
post religion in this in the way that we
sometimes believe
because he says in in 24 for example the
specialization of power it still
maintains hierarchy just as religion did
but now no one thinks that they're
involved in in unconsciousness whereas
the technology
the mass media technology is it exists
only to
continue the dream to keep the dream
going such that no one wakes up
so it's not necessarily pointing to a
better time it's just pointing to you
know you're not better we're not
progressing this isn't this isn't the
march of History where we're all
suddenly awakened and informed consumers
and individuals no we're we're part of
the new religion and no one really
realizes it I love that I love to I
always love the Benny mean quote that
relates to that when he says that the
the age of technological reproducibility
falsifies that heraclitus's statement
that every man when awake lives in a
world of common and one falls asleep in
a dream has a world of their own that
falsifies that statement now we're all
in a collective dream world kind of
thing that's kind of what the spectacle
is like as well and it's Collective
dream worlds
reality is gone and he even says he even
kind of says he doesn't say it's gone
here it's not again like the the reality
part isn't part of the historical
argument he just says you know it's not
something added to the real world it's
it's the very heart of society's real
unreality
it's the heart of society's real
and then a nine he says in a world that
really has been turned on its head truth
is a moment of falsehood
truth becomes a moment of the illusion
our truth becomes a necessary stage
through which falsehood has to pass is
true and the fact that everything is a
false Choice also it's not like you can
go to the Soviet Union or to China and
have a more real relationship because he
says those are concentrated spectacles
you get to a personality cult because
there there's still no
mechanism of response and feedback with
the spectacle the spectacle produces
and he's like really I I think this must
have been like kind of controversial at
the time because we've talked about May
68 this was written a year before that
but he's he's saying like maoism it's a
personality
cult
of the spectacle it's a spectacle to
make sure that people only think about
Mao and never actually think about their
relations to what he calls real stuff
production
right so there's no I don't know that he
ever says there's a real place where
this ever existed or does exist all he
notices is the splits of the splits and
the splits of the splits don't need to
be split they could be something
different
so I guess that's his uh yeah I mean I
think I agree I definitely would never
read him as thinking that there's some
kind of like Natural State we can return
to
but I do think you know there's some
kind of implicit space of kind of
optimism one of the things that I notice
Being Framed throughout is this idea of
the what the spectacle is causing in
individuals so you know kind of becoming
passive Spectators of the spectacle
and we talked a little bit about
passivity and activity which we don't
need to get into that debate anymore but
I think it's it does feel like there's a
way in which even though I'm not reading
him or as saying there's something we
can return to
but by pointing out the effect that this
spectacle is happening having on social
relationships
as a kind of passivity
implied in that and I think this kind of
bears out is that there's some way of
activating reactivating something more
real
um
so it's not so much a return but it's
like
by pointing out what the spectacle is
doing
there's an implied call for some
alternative possibility
which I'm skeptical of it's also like
like he said yeah like he's here's one
of the moments in in 16 where he says
that the spectacle subjects living human
beings to its will to the extent that
the economy has brought them under its
sway
so there's necessity to go out and buy
the means of survival and the spectacle
acts like a veneer or a paste over all
of that
and it it takes over from that that
necessity
transforming that necessity into from
from a kind of alienated production of
Commodities to to an alienated
consumption of images basically
so it shapes our it shapes our
production productive relations in a in
a different way and it probably shapes
our consumer behavior in a different way
and now if that's not becoming passive
then I don't know what is
right in a sense that you're not
again like I said
you know you know you're not buying a
car because of its specs you're buying a
car because of the the image and the
lifestyle that's presented to you which
has nothing to do with the car
whatsoever has nothing to do with the
people making the car it has nothing to
do with the company or the factory or
the brand it's just something completely
it's just there is it false or true I
mean even that's like kind of irrelevant
right I mean that's that's Surplus he
calls that sort of Surplus Survival
anyway but like I guess we could all
admit at this point that like owning a
cell phone is almost like a survival
thing who can live without one anymore
and so
where's the activity and passivity in
that you're compelled to do this you
have a series of choices to make those
choices are based on images those images
present various Lifestyles or they're
going to buy an Android or an apple
whatever and then you have the Apple
people and they fight over which one's
better with the Android people I like I
like the apps and the open technology
well no but this was so much more user
friendly
all that's [__] irrelevant that's the
content of the spectacle who gives a
[__]
the point is you need a phone to survive
it's got all this other stuff bells and
whistles but I mean again what's
what's before that
I don't think well in ancient Greece you
need to you need a stone tablet don't
stop even don't even remember that stuff
yeah there's no the worry the worry that
he has is with propaganda the propaganda
that you even have a choice because
every choice is false you're allowed to
have a choice because it doesn't disrupt
anything real
you are that's always been true it can
colonize your mental experience
because you are already subjugated
economically so you can have your
culture wars you can have your pretend
fights in the spectacle you can make
your choices in the spectacle just
because none of that's real you can vote
for the PCF because they're going to do
Revolution you can vote vote for Bernie
because Bernie's gonna do the revolution
but in the end all of this stuff is
spectacular or I like the way you want a
way out he doesn't give the way out but
if you want to if you want any way out
you have to at least understand how
profound the problem is and just because
something has never been true doesn't
mean it never will be true
I like I like the way he puts it that
the the choice has already been made and
the the spectacle is a celebration of
those choices that have already been
made
and it's a latent justification yeah I
mean I think I I like I like the way
that that pills put it there that like
just because it it has never been the
case doesn't mean it's not going to be
the case
or and and specifically that it's about
pointing out the like how fundamental
the problem is I think my view is just
that the problem is actually more
fundamental than just the spectacle the
problem is human beings the way that
they are
like so the spectacle is just a
production of human beings
uh but but I feel like the the
profundity of the problem doesn't stop
at the spectacle it stops at the kinds
of creatures we are
so I mean a way I'm more of a Doomer
than him well his solution to the
problem was shooting himself in the
heart
well I I think that the way did he oh
yeah he went out he went out with a bang
literally yeah not so great in the end I
didn't know that [__] oh I think the way
like the way it continues for Marxist
analysis does bring it down to that
level right because humans like it it
comes yes sure it comes always from the
need to survive we need food we need
clothing we need those basic things we
need shelter
and that you know this is an extension
of that you know I I don't know I'm not
I don't want to go too far with that but
it is in it is in marks there right
there is there is attention to these
needs these basic needs and so if if the
spectacle is
an extension of capital in a certain way
then that's that stuff should already be
in here
and it is he says Surplus Survival so he
makes that sort of point
so it's not it's not like it it leaves
out the human and like those fundamental
things I don't think
but I mean those those things fall into
the background right because consumption
we're not thinking about survival when
we're consuming even though that's what
we're doing when we go out and buy food
right are we thinking are we counting
calories if so why but most in most
cases we're buying our favorite Brands
we're buying the foods we're used to
We're Not Making survival decisions so
that stuff's kind of irrelevant even
though it does underlie it in some very
fundamental way it's not factored in
because we've in a way we've moved past
all of that
we're not Shipwrecked Sailors trying to
find water and shelter from Sun and and
vitamin C so we don't get scurvy we're
we're we're we're entertaining ourselves
if I can point to one
philosophical moment in here that I
thought was good but he never elaborated
on it because he barely elaborates on
anything it's just
all of our problems are the same cause
and the cause is the spectacle which you
know gets tiring I I that's why I wonder
kind of who the audience is for this it
must be a public audience or something
like that well it's almost like a slogan
right because see some of these were
some of the most popular things people
would graffiti around on on 68 some of
these things yeah
well he says the soul when I first was
that from pills which one
the one that you were just reading the
quote what aphorism that wasn't a
quotation that was me which one oh
sorry I thought I thought you were just
gonna read oh I was good I was gonna
twelve twelve he says the soul message
of the spectacle and you guys have heard
me say this everyone's heard me say this
because I love it what is good appears
and what appears is good
so it's a monopoly of appearances and
this means that if you see it's good and
this I I think Victor this might if we
went into it a little deeper I know
we're kind of nearing the end instead of
the beginning but if we went into it a
little deeper
you can see this as a coherent
manipulation of human experience in that
yeah you're going to think what good
appears or what what is good appears if
that's the only thing that you see and
if you're told every day what your needs
are
you're you probably don't have the
psychic resources to defend against that
and I think that's part of what he's
calling this this false Unity here
but his little philosophy point I mean I
agree with that
I think that's true
that like what he's describing
I think my sort of black pill Doomer is
that like people want to be told what to
do like most people like
I think that that's no different than
before when people like the attraction
of religion in like Medieval Times
uh
uh the fact that those things became so
popular I feel is is indicative of
uh kind of existential condition of of
uncertainty and looking for an answer
and effectively looking for someone just
were primed for some Force to tell us
what to do and it was religion and now
it's
consumerism
I don't think anyone actually listening
to this podcast would would disagree
with you because all we do this podcast
and they listen to it because we can be
like we are outside of it we're not in
it which is of course number one we're
outside of it yeah here's his philosophy
point that I want to elaborate on if I
can real quick to finish this up because
he says yeah the spectacle inherits the
weakness of the western philosophical
project so he's doing historiography
Western philosophy is one project
and back to quotation which attempted to
understand activity by means of the
categories of vision and it is based on
the Relentless development of the
particular technical rationality that
grew out of that form of thought
which is for him Vision so we now have
appearances replacing reality Plato was
worried about it beaudreyard celebrates
it in in his weird way
and if you want to call the Western
philosophical project one thing
that kind of starts with Play-Doh
you go look the cave allegory what is
reason
s the light and the truth is the Sun and
what's the soul like the soul is like
the eye the soul is like the chief among
the senses Aristotle says and then like
you just said we got the Bible God
coming in and John says God's light
there's no there's no darknesses
darkness in him
and I
I like what does light what does light
and sight provide it is distance it is
separation from things separation from
objects and you have these external
um non-reciprocal relationships because
you can see stuff from far away like
touch you can't this is merlu Ponte you
can't touch anything without it touching
you that's a reciprocal relationship so
to have knowledge as a form of sight
sight is our project and this is the
end of the project now I don't think
that ideas matter I don't think this is
like a causal thing that we've been
working towards the whole time sure but
I do agree with him that there is a
different way to conceive of it and I
wish you spent some time on it because I
would I would be fascinated by it but
he's moving on but just what a
philosophical work well we read some of
his stuff on the Watts Riots and on on
the city you have to read uh his
comments he doesn't have like a full set
of comments you'd have to read or
something
yeah I think we'll do that soon but
like specialization means distance it
means like a scientist with a cold-eyed
view of reality and this is like the
culmination not the not the effect not
like it was caused by an idea but it is
the culmination of that sort of world
where everything is fragmented so if we
can go back to some sense of the one or
the Limitless or we're all connected I
think that would be in his mind a better
basis for not just a sociology but an an
ontology that
we can hardly get back to I think we can
sense it but it's hardly there anymore
yeah I think he does say um
the vision is the most abstract of the
senses and the most easily deceived he
says and it's the most he says readily
adaptable to present day society's
generalized abstraction which I believe
he's saying is occurring through this
spectacles generalized abstraction so
vision is the most conducive to this
it's a it's a pointing out our our
modern ocular centrism right vision is
the dominant
mode of perception
I don't know whatever whatever mcluhan
says about it it's it's linear it's
sequential it's geared towards logic and
modern thought and that and the
spectacle is is
totally taking advantage of this
from our our visual our Reliance on
visuality we we began this talking about
pornography which is a which is a
eminently visual activity
oh wiping your ass is a pretty visual
activity too
is it well I can't look at my ass while
I wipe it well you gotta check how do
you know when you're done how do you
know when you're done wiping
do you know some people don't check oh
my God freaks oh my God what the hell I
don't check you do you have a mirror in
your toilet or something what's going on
here no you don't look at you don't look
at that look at that
look at that see if there's anything
left that kind of chicken that kind of I
got a bidet [__] yeah that's
got
it's Visual and and I don't know I I
came by I come by these sorts of
products again through commercials and
and
the internet
can we can we do five minutes of
critique I'm I've been holding my mouth
shut and I know I feel like I've been
doing all this critique this whole time
no I I know I've been trying to I want
to bust it out to be like this is why
this book is a big deal and I can
understand if you've never heard in any
of this before
if you're like an artist then this would
be like really inspiring if you've never
heard it before it'd be really inspiring
if you feel all these things kind of
like at a
a non-non theoretical level then it
would be great but I found this so
tiring to go through it's just like
irrefutable assertation after
irrefutable assertation and you're like
okay where did this come from where draw
me some links tell me when this happened
tell me why this happened and tell me
like the development of cause and effect
that led to this thing and I know that's
not the point and I know I'm probably
not the intended audience but this thing
just made me be like I wanna I'd rather
read bodegaard I'd rather read someone
who but also all right I gotta shut
myself up a bit I don't think he's
writing for philosophers I don't even
think he was
a philosopher he was intending to be
provocative and he was
and
look the the back of my book says this
the debordian analysis of Modern Life
resonates more deeply and Darkly than
perhaps even its creator thought
possible
from The New Yorker
so the spectacle justifying itself I I
don't know I wanted way more from this
text it was extremely repetitive and it
just accounted all problems up to a
singular cause and the cause's name is
the spectacle and I'm like come on dude
you can do you can do a little more than
that yeah well this style is certainly a
lot to get over because it is aphoristic
these are Theses these are just numbered
Theses and you kind of have to spend
time with them
because it's like there's a pact a lot
there's a lot of complicated sentences
here and you gotta kind of unpack what's
happening it's not
it's not presented in a in an academic
way with an introduction and a thesis
and a series of paragraphs with with
details and and discussion it's not
presented in that style at all so it's
very frustrating
because you got to pick up you got to be
like okay when's he gonna come back to
this idea not to not for like 30 more
Theses or something and then even like
sometimes only briefly in the in certain
Theses and they're all different lengths
so sometimes some of them are just one
line some of them are big chunks
and everything in between it's a little
bit
it's a little bit difficult to just sit
down read through it and then get a
sense of what's going on you have to
really like go back through it and look
at each one and
try to make connections to other ones I
don't know I think you're I think your
time would be spent better on different
books yeah I feel like there's just
better books to read that that that
unpack the claims like a lot better A
lot more extensively I'm not as familiar
with Beau Gerard but from what I do know
I get the sense as pills was saying that
would be a good example
and I think lots of other philosophers
touch on these themes uh so it's not
clear to me why and I remember that when
I first read it that few years ago my
experience was very similar
where I just felt like what why is this
so like well
regarded like this is not
philosophically all that robust
and and it seems like this person is
saying stuff that a lot of other
philosophers were saying at the time so
maybe the answer to that question is
just because it's associated with that
kind of artistic movement of the
situations International so there's kind
of a a linkage to a certain cultural
movement an artistic movement that was
happening at the time that adds an aura
of
importance to what in my opinion is just
not that robust and yeah there's Rich
moments there's flashes of insights of
course
uh but it's it just felt thin and
shallow to me at times because it was so
based on assertions we were kind of
talking about this in our group chat and
I was expressing frustration about how
it was like aggressively assertive and
then just like making these claims
and Eric who's being much more generous
to the text you know well it's aphorisms
you know it's supposed to be
like this and that's fair enough I just
felt like you know there's a lot of
philosophers who I think are a lot more
richer who use that aphoristic style
Wittgenstein Nietzsche
who really unpack their claims in in a
way that I felt that this this text just
doesn't do so
maybe the Society of this spectacle is
exactly the type of book that the
Society of spectacle would produce next
week we're doing uh philosophical
investigations uh no problemo that's a
good book
I mean yeah I I don't know I like if you
spend because obviously it's not easy
you got to spend time with it figure it
out if you spend that kind of time with
this text would would you get as much
out of it
and how much of wittenstein's popularity
is just analytic philosophers cow Towing
and boot licking and how much of it is
really actually on to something uh honey
I'm not saying he's not I'm just saying
there's definitely a mixture in there
there's no there's no institutionalized
form equivalent to analytic philosophy
that has a bunch of people that'll rally
around the board to defend them like
wittenstein has and yet
is to boards just less valuable than
what vicenstein's wrote I wouldn't jump
to that conclusion but there was an
institution aside from who's better even
if we measure this in a weird-ass boxing
match of who's the better aphoristic
writer still if you think of yourself as
a leftist
and your primary activity of a leftist
like ours is disseminating opinions on
platforms owned by billionaires then you
are a spectacular leftist sure and you
know now we know what spectacular means
it's fake ass [__] culture War fake ass
[__] the right exists because they talk
about the left the left exists because
they talk about the right and it's a
reinforcing mechanism so that you never
actually look at anything that involves
actual ownership
you could say real ownership or real
Labor Relations
so everyone's a [__] fake and that's
something that he was way more right
about
now than he was even when he when he
wrote it
yeah no that's fair I and I agree with I
want to be clear though that for me it
doesn't come down to whether or not I
agree with the text like I think
Wittgenstein is someone that I happen to
just philosophically agree with what
he's up to in that in philosophical
investigations but Nietzsche is someone
who I have like really strong
disagreements with but I feel
does a much better job of of
walking you through what it is they're
talking about so like Nietzsche will
spend aphorisms
giving kind of mocking accounts of what
like you know sometimes mocking not
always accounts of what he's arguing
against uh and I felt that this was much
more declaratory if that's a word it
just was like declaring that this is the
way the world is
but yes I mean I still think that all in
all the analysis what pill said I don't
disagree with him you know he's on to
something real in this text about the
effect and spectacular
uh I was thinking also briefly about
something I saw the other day there's
like the biggest YouTuber I think is is
Mr Beast if you guys know who that is
yeah and and he recently had like it was
funny because he made a video about how
he paid for like a thousand people to
get their eyesight back
and everyone was talking was like
criticizing him and like yeah I mean
because he's turning I guess something
like that into a spectacle
uh but the reaction was kind of funny to
me just the way that they're like he's
like I'm using my money to actually help
people but I guess anyway that's a whole
other can of worms yeah I mean people
were yeah I saw a bit of that yeah
people were either complaining that he's
just doing it to get views
which is a pre-packaged response to
literally every single thing you see on
anything I don't know why anyone bothers
to even say that and other people were
like no he's bringing attention to how
shitty Healthcare is in the States
because he was paying for Florida I mean
again those are that's this that's the
spectacle there like that that response
those are all pre-packaged responses
for views that's the only point of doing
anything yeah the internet yes I mean
all of it goes without saying speaking
of your charitability to Nature about
making claims and then diving deep into
them what doesn't kill me makes me
stronger what does that apply to
does it apply to cyanide does it apply
to inhaling carbon monoxide just a
little bit of it that makes but I think
he actually but if you but yes I agree
just that one African by itself but if
you pay attention to everything else he
says I think he's pretty concrete
about the value that exerting yourself
will have in your life
that the most meaningful things are
things that you push yourself to
overcome it all fits in with his view of
like overcoming self-overcoming as the
the kind of formative struggle
so yes on its own I agree
but I think if you read it in context it
makes sense
I mean I think if we say those things
and bring that level of Charity to this
we could say something similar
and and in a way you know the board at
least
[__] this is a low blow but like I
mean yeah at least the board's not
caught up in the middle of like [__]
far right debates right now as far as I
know maybe is maybe maybe he's going
around on those right-wing social media
things like Nietzsche is but I mean at
least he's got that going for him but
the point is if we brought that level of
of patience to this text I'm sure those
same sorts of things would come out and
I'm not it's not true evidence but I
mean this wealth wealth of Articles I'm
sure if I did a brief search on
Nietzsche I'd find the same thing but
much more less culture studies more
philosophy here it's just reams of
Articles using the board's theories to
talk about poverty or to talk about
social media Etc
and I I think it's it would be an
interesting exercise to look at what
these people are getting out of the
board and then we go back to this text
and look at it and be like is it there
is it there maybe it is like best in
calner the famous postmodern writers
wrote that for the board the spectacle
is a tool of pacification and
depoliticization it is a permanent Opium
War which supervise social subjects and
distracts them from the most urgent task
of real life which is recovering the
full range of their human powers through
revolutionary change okay so if they can
get that out of this then I'm sure we
can we can do I mean what you said about
Nietzsche sounds a lot like this
self-overcoming recovering human powers
through revolutionary change Collective
action that sort of thing right it's
here it's less individualistic granted
it's more Marxist granted but it's here
and framed in this way
so I mean it's not like it's bankrupt of
ideas it's it's no totally I mean I said
I said I also disagreed with Nietzsche
by the way but yes I mean I I don't I'm
not saying it's bankrupt but anyway
briefly pills before you talk I just
wanted to say speaking of nature I
really enjoyed really really liked your
use and abuses of History uh Nietzsche
video I think that'd be a fun thing to
talk about one day but anyway go on
thank you
um per I guess wrapping up yeah oh that
opium the Opium War thing that's a
direct quote from this text I think it's
yeah it's number 44. is it chapter okay
yeah because the opiate war is like
we're gonna just bring a whole bunch of
addictive drugs into
the Chinese populace and get them
addicted to it so there's too stupid to
ever be able to fight back because they
just wanna
they're they're all addicted and that's
the thing with the with the spectacle
the Opium of the masses
yeah he says he says it's a permanent
the spectacles of permanent Opium War
wage to make it impossible to
distinguish goods from Commodities or
true satisfaction from a survival that
increases according to its own logic
yeah you you create the need and then
police its distribution
for the owner and that survival that
increases according to its own logic was
kind of what I was trying to say earlier
is that that's that that Foundation of
of necessity that this stuff is built on
I don't know how you would disagree with
that I'm excited to like looking forward
in the book I'm especially excited to
get to
uh five and six which are time in
history and spectacular time so maybe
we'll do that yeah I want to get into
some of the stuff on celebrities too as
the what is it the apparent experts on
real life or something
the the celebrity is the apparent
individual that absolutely obliterates
individuality
yeah and he speaks of movie stars and
and Mao in the same sentence
yeah I wanted to ask
because I'm I'm I've been bouncing this
word around in my head a little bit
but post Marxist now the board is
unabashedly Marxist he's Marx is kind of
the only actual reference in this book
even though it's mostly indirect
and uh I think you'd call someone like
boudreada a Marxist who got over it
reformed would you see that in this text
because I think a lot of the uh a lot of
the buzz around it is still
kind of it it wants to lose the
Revolutionary aspect of it and just deal
with here's how the how here's how
social media is giving you eating
disorders
or seeing at least the proletariat class
is no longer like
something applicable for Marxist
analysis no I would I would ask the
question have post marxists used a board
because he's before the post-marxism is
70s right it was a Chantal move it was
first person to coin that or or yeah and
move together I think it was worried
about them wasn't it oh it might have
been coins I think they coined it in in
their book in the 70s I can't remember
if they did I mean I actually deal with
them a lot in my dissertation
I don't know if they actually use the
term post-marxist but they have a lot of
criticisms for Doctrine air Marxist
which might be why people called them
that but they might have used the
Germans possible I'd like to I'd like to
recoid it
yeah for this
remit it no I I don't mean specifically
for this but like the the turn from
this analysis and all its parallels with
sort of postmodern Theory
um not the lib appropriation of Deborah
that's the that's not post Marxist but
actually like saying
there's actual problems with Marxism in
the sense that these critiques can no
longer apply and the board implies that
while never moving away from Marx which
kind of makes him not a non-marxist but
a post Marxist he says this the
relations of production in terms of
images are no longer the same critiques
as those of the commodity I'd like to
get into that more if we could all right
I gotta correct myself as the term first
appeared in 1985 in hegemony and
socialist strategy there we go that's
where you came from that makes sense the
clown move coin to term in 85 that's
where it came from but I mean yeah it's
fair to say yeah Gita boards definitely
like gesturing and that sort of like
Direction but I don't think he's Left
Behind the fundamentals of Marxism in
quite
that way
Spectators you've heard us talk on the
internet now we invite you to comment on
the internet and we can just keep the
cycle going endlessly
but we'll talk at you next week and
thanks till we return
all right doing this just for views or
we're trying to bring attention to the
uh terrible state of uh podcasting in
general
that's the question Victor go feed your
cat or your your friend's cat all right
would you say they're meowists guy cut
cut cut that out please I'm not I'm not
it describes a lot of people I know
all right cheers
see ya
oops I forgot to stop
[Music]